[Music]
that's right
celebrity income breakdown we also call
this piece George Washington is on
cocaine
now listen we're going to find out where
their income comes from for example we
did some research Guy Fieri
check it out 60% of his money comes from
on-air talent 20% comes from producer
20% human grill brush that's a lot of
money
look at this one Mike Pence 30% Indiana
governor's salary 20% attorney fees 50%
people paying him to walk away from
[Applause]
scooby-doo we find out Scooby Doo's into
prey that yeah yeah that's right thanks
for ever buying this Andy scooby-doo 60%
relevation 10% rubies 30% a run servant
of Rixx of Rudess Apple runs Miley Cyrus
Miley Cyrus 3% yoo-hoo memmio
30% I'm on the voice now sugars 40% fine
I stick a rubber chicken in my hoo-ha
[Applause]
Rudy Giuliani Rudy Giuliani 20% speaking
fees 20% consulting fees 60% modeling
fees for what rabies looks like in
humans posters Ryan Lochte we find out
how Ryan Lochte makes his money yeah 27%
swimming swam Olympic medals bra they
present him examined ballroom dancing
yeah
65% tax fraud yo David Spade check this
out David Spade 25% book sales 45%
stand-up appearances 30% new line of
children's mustache you know John G
stump he's the CEO of Wells Fargo they
just had that scandal
yeah 50% of his money from customers
savings accounts 40% money from
customers checking accounts 10% money
from customers hey wait what do you mean
I'm under arrest
it's my bank don't I get to keep it all
the money in it I don't oh man I have a
lot to learn about how banks work
[Applause]
and finally Nicholas Cage yeah 20 we
didn't do anything yet we just showed
his picture
for God's sake what's wrong with you
people
you show a picture of Nic Cage and
they're like what is Conan Daley gonna
be rich Nic Cage 20 percent yes I'll do
your movie 20 percent I'm driving the
set right now 20 percent okay I'm in
here in makeup 10% will someone please
say action 30 percent I'm here for
celebrity income breakdown the movie
where is everyone
went a little break that's how these
things work
you